Hello and welcome everyone, to ActInf
Livestream number 38 two. It's February
23, 2022. Welcome to ActInf
Lab. We are a participatory online lab
that is communicating, learning, and
practicing applied active inference.
You can find us at the links here on
this page. This is a recorded and an
archived livestream, so please provide
us with feedback so that we can improve
our work. All backgrounds and
perspectives are welcome and will follow
good video etiquette for live streams.
Go to activeinprints.org to learn more
about how to participate in any of these
live streams, which are part of the
Comma Communications Organizational unit
or just any other part of the lab. All
right, today in Active stream number 38
two, we're going to be having our third
discussion. There is the zero, the one,
and now the two on this paper, the
Evolution of Brain Architectures for
Predictive Coding and Active Inference.
And maybe each of us have a few
ideas in mind and I'm sure we'll come up
with a few other things. Plus, if
anyone's watching live, they can write a
comment in the chat. So we'll start with
just introduction, saying anything
if we want about the paper before just
jumping in somewhere or somewhere else.
I'm Daniel, I'm a researcher in
California, and I will pass it to Dean.
Hi, I'm Dean. I'm up here in Calgary and
I'm not doing very much except
trying to keep up with all the papers
that we're looking at in active
inference. And I'll pass it down to
Bleu. I'm Bleu.
I'm a research consultant in New Mexico,
and I really enjoyed this paper
for many reasons. My background in
neuroscience not, like,
being a priority, but yeah, it is. So
I'm excited to get into it and to
discuss some of the points that I picked
up with you guys.
Okay, well,
Bleu joining us today.
What figure can we start with? Or start
with a blank sheet and just any of
the points that you'd like to raise or
we can do something else.
Man, figure four for me was like,
awesome. So maybe that was my favorite
figure. Maybe that's the one we should
start with. Okay, all right,
so what was your just perspective
on what figure four was and then what
did it mean or why was it interactions
for you? So I was
interested in this figure and maybe
like, even in how this figure could be
expanded in terms of hierarchical depth
and temporal depth. And temporal depth
has more than one potential scale which
isn't really mentioned here.
Temporal depth can be thought of as
small time steps. What am I going to do
next? What's my next action? But also in
bigger time steps, what is the next
interactions of me and how these
hierarchical depths? Because that's
obviously like a larger levels
hierarchy, like the next iteration of me
as a species or as a human species.
Right? Like, what is the next
interactions of the species versus what
is the next action I'm going to perform
as part of the species. So that was kind
of an interactions like perspectival
dance that they took and just really
like the multi dimensionality of
this and how to kind of think about it
in like, maybe like is this like
a multi dimensional space in terms
of like, my cells, what are my cells
going to do next? My tissues, my organs,
knee, active inference lab, lab.
What are all these things going to do
next? And also on that level, is that
like a short time frame or is it like a
large time free? And do the time frames
differ or can the same hierarchical
level have more than one time frame or
not?
Okay, nice questions. Dean, what do you
think about any of that as we start to
look at figure four as a starting point
for talking more about what Bleu just
mentioned? Well, I think one
of the things we touched on in the .1
was the idea that within a frame there's
also an orthogonal mesh. So as we push
through this representation from the
bottom up, are we going from what might
be described as an architectural
existence to at the top, what we
might describe as architectural
learning? Now, of course,
if we take that position, we have to be
careful that we're not reinforcing the
idea that it's all about constructivism
all the time versus being creative.
Right. Like, I think you need to be a
little bit of both. And I'm not being
creationist, like, not one story that
carries for it all the way through time
as Bleu kind of ref there,
but the idea that the updating matters
throughout the time scale that you
choose to look at. And so now the
question is, is architectures the lens
that we should be using to talk about
how we advance from mere existence to a
place that we would describe as
learning?
I mean, that's what it was chosen here.
But is that the one way now?
Right? It's a way. It's a good way.
Certainly make something super, super
complex into something that's just
complicated. But is it the only way? I
don't know.
Just one question
of clarification. When you said this is
the only way, what were you referring to
this figure for? Or what?
To the idea of an architectures. Right.
The architectures lens, as opposed to
other ways that we might build out this
idea of going from homeostatic evidence
to going from unknowing to knowing
and whatever that means.
Okay, thanks for sharing
it. Just to kind of maybe connect this.
You mentioned architectural disturbance,
which is within the metered space.
Whatever the metric is or the measure or
the grids that you draw, there's a
distance within a map and that's like
the ecological transect. That's the
Blueprint, that's the forensic analysis.
And then that's like parametric learning
because it's a distortion of parameters
in a given space and then
fully defined, not just like space for
openness whereas the architectural
learning is at the structural level,
architectural. And then that was kind of
like what you related to not just the
homeostatic or even the allostasis
perhaps, but something that's like the
sort of unknown, unknown open
ended ness, biological open,
evolutionary trajectories. So not just
sustaining it, but actually realizing
it.
So we'll just get a few notes on each of
these transformations, then see what
other ones or like what are some
situations that might model and then
also return to the questions that were
raised early by Bleu, like with the
multilevel self and where's
mental action or thought.
In this model, the examples were
provided of like, for example, the Alo
stat that took the temperature homeostat
and then added in in their example like
the Sunrise visual detector and modeler
column. And so that gave the
anticipatory change in body temperature
when the sun was viewed. But then
is there a similar structure for
cognition? Is it just like linking
together senses in more and more
combinatoric way? It's a very sense
oriented perspective which from an
evolutionary perspective, which is what
this paper is exploring, that's the one
to ground further elaborations and
changes on rather than trying to reverse
from something like engaging
counterfactuals. So just using an active
inference model, sometimes for a
counterfactual agent, if the model says
that that's okay or doing the bacteria
without implying that it's doing the
counterfactual explicitly, that might be
possible too.
So we have thermal regulation in the
paper. But then the question is, does
that equate to feelings in a human
being? Right?
Like if all that feelings cover
necessarily collapse down to the example
of thermal regulation? And at what point
are we aware of the fact that there
might be a difference between the
example and the concept? Like where
in this figure four is that blurry
line that we cross? It's a good
question. I don't know where it is
subtina. You're talking about feelings
like emotions or feelings like
sensations or both? Yeah, all of that,
right? Like so feelings tends to take on
a big sort of it's more detached from
the example of thermal regulation. And
yet that's just the fact that you can
ask that question proves out that maybe
the one example doesn't cover all of the
different aspects of the higher concept,
right? That's where the scaling part
comes in. So it's not just temporal
depth that allows for that. You have to
have the temporal depth and the
hierarchical depth what
kind of feelings are you talking about?
Implies that there's more than
one way that has to exist for you
to come at that to ask that question
where do we draw the partition?
Right? So in here they
show duplication. But I'm not going
to say it misleads, but it potentially
mislead if you think that there's a
linearity to this. But in fact, a couple
of times Daniel talked in the .1 about
the fact that there is a step function
moment. There is a jump. It's not a
jump. I forget about
one example where we can't say you just
go from one eye to two just because I
think that was one of the examples you
gave Daniel. But at some over
evolutionary time there is these little
progressions where if you look back on
it, it seems like a rather large jump
took place. Right?
Let me give a few points there.
So when you said, like the big jumps and
so in one sense that's related
to the kind of discussion around complex
patterns of evolution and some
phenotypes or genotype regions that are
very stable through long periods of
time. Over many generations, like the
ultra conserved elements in the genome
that have very low mutation rates versus
regions that have high mutation rates,
et cetera. And then same as phenotypes,
like phenotypes that are very constant,
like the silicon fish or phenotypes that
are very plastic or dynamic or ones that
we just don't have the records of.
And then how to connect what is
happening or the models that we want to
make in humans, especially with computer
enabled and language enabled humans,
technology enabled humans with the
continuum of cognitive processes.
And then you said like, it's not linear.
And then that kind of image
me think like there's like feelings,
which is still a rich qualitative
area, like you brought out like
sensations but also experiences and
emotions. And then how quickly,
securely or unambiguously can we
map just that cloud of concepts just to
be like it's a policy selection on
attention, it's an uncertainty on
valence, it's valence. Like we're
doing the parametric cognition model
with this, but it's still even a little
bit open. What this represents. Is this
the evolutionary biologists doing model
testing on a phylogenetic tree? Or is
this talking about the genomic or the
neurophysiological components that have
to be connected just anatomically for a
certain function to arise? And that
is the rich area that there's so much to
explore in too. Well, I think the one
thing we can agree on is because we're
talking about evolution, we're talking
about history. So it is backwards
looking and backwards looking is easier
than looking into the future, right?
So I think that's one thing we can agree
on. But what this is trying to do is
explain perhaps how the history came
about. So one
thing that the authors mentioned as well
and that's kind of Linsker to the idea
of feelings. This was a
discussion about the evolution of brain
architectures. But there's also the fact
that brains are in bodies. They don't
just exist in jars. For me at
least, I feel like I feel like
emotions, not necessarily sensations,
but I feel like emotions are driven in a
large part by the body.
We've made a huge kind of connection
between the gut and the brain and
there's probably more connections to be
felt because I feel feelings,
like emotions deeply in my body. Like,
I feel them in my heart or I feel in my
stomach or I feel, like, in my pinky
toe. So I really think that the idea of
emotions can't be separated
from embodiment. But prediction, I think
it's a mental activity, or at least I
feel it in my brain. So I don't know if
that's the same kind of sensation that
everyone has, but prediction is,
in my mind, a brain thing. But I know
that's overriding. If someone throws a
Bull at me, I put my hand up like that's
a reflux. But is that like my brain
driving my body? I'm not sure, really.
But I know that there's some prediction
that's maybe not mental, that's more
like physical or that's more embodied is
probably the right word.
And you kind of move into that intuitive
space as well. Right? Like, if you think
about going to the beach, I can't tell
whether you're going to think about the
wetness aspects of that, the warmness
part of that, the smell of the sunscreen
part of that. But you're going to but
that prediction isn't going to also
generate embodied emotions.
Even though you may not articulate them.
Right. You're still intuiting them,
you're still anticipating them. And so
I'm not sure how the architectures pulls
that out, especially to Daniel's point,
where our form has
adapted evolutionarily to the
phenotypical situation that we find
ourselves in. And going forward,
let's say that sea levels rise and
suddenly you have beachfront property
where for millions of years you did not.
How does that affect now your emotions?
Right. I like the architectural
idea of being able to take something and
look at the historicity of it and be
able to explain it out with a little bit
more confidence.
I'm not sure, though. I'm still
struggling with being able to figure out
how, if we want to look ahead,
we can necessarily set it up the layered
way it was set up here. And I really
like figure four, but I just have
to categorize it and keep it where it's
most useful, which is in the backwards
facing part of this. That's all.
Okay, let's return to how to use this.
That sounds like a good question, but
we'll get there. So Lou
brought up the brain and compliment with
the body. And this was just the quote
from the very final lines of the paper,
or near the ends, where they
acknowledged that partial perspective
that they presented in the paper.
Partial learning. Just a portion of,
but also partial, like partial to a
certain view because there was a
neuroscience regime of attention. And
that's the contribution that was made
that helps apply to other systems. And
then there's another synthesis to be
made. And this is kind of like the
opening where they just acknowledge that
cognition can be extended and embodied.
And it suggests that not all aspects of
control need to be solved by or
represented a central generative models.
So it's this point that we've come to
from many different angles from like,
the ecological and the cognitive and
then here from more of a structure
learning perspective that like the
representation, whether just in the
model of a system or in the system's own
self representation. It doesn't have to
be the exact same thing as some
latent variable in the outside world.
So it's possible to have like an
effective model of climate action
without a perfectly accuracy model.
But that has to be understood within
like was brought up a space of
counterfactuals of what could happen
from the outside world where we really
never can eradicate the total
distribution and also the introduction
of the unknown unknowns. And so that's
the fundamental openness of the external
states and the modelers view.
And then there's still a lot to
explore with the counterfactuals of the
models that the system that like
the agent is can implement.
But I think that gets a little bit of
how to start to use it in
a certain area.
Any thoughts or what? I got a question
for you, Dean. When you study dance,
for example, and they're foraging and I
think it's section eight or I forget
what section that they say foraging
really, really matters. I think if we're
point toing this now, I think that the
sort of the go forward piece of this is
now, when you started looking at ants,
did you start from a cognition? I don't
know what your background is, but did
you start from a position of sort of
pulling apart the historicity of why
that thing is now sort of laid out the
way it is? I know there's a
piece of that that's there. But is that
the place where most people that begin a
study start? Which is kind of
interesting about this paper because to
me going from existence
to learning implies a certain history.
And so I'm wondering how you sort of
come at things when you see them
foraging where history fits in
terms of that you gaining some
understanding of what's happening here
as opposed to then what happens.
Great question. The topic is
historiosity and foraging for 400 from
Dean Bleu. What would you say on the
topic first? How would you bring that
together? What would be some important
points? So I
really like this idea also and I have a
completely unrelated point and then an
unrelated question. It says mechanisms
of memory and planning have evolved from
mechanisms of navigation in the physical
world. And some super interesting that I
thought. Side point was if you've never
read the book, deep Work by Cal Newport.
He talks about memorizing a deck of
cards. If you haven't read the book,
read the book. But it's interesting
because he goes through a very elaborate
way to memorize a deck of cards and it's
through building a memory palace. And so
in this memory palace, you have a place
that you know very well, like your own
house. You can imagine walking through
your door. You imagine the porch, the
doorstep, how it looks. You imagine the
doorway, all the rooms, all the closets.
Like, you imagine going through your
house, taking a tour, and exploring each
room in a very systematic way. So it's
very easy to memorize a route you would
take to your house. Like, say you're
looking for a ghost in your closet or
something, hiding in your house. How
would you look? So you go through your
house, so you have this palace,
right, that you have in your mind. And
then he talks about making every card
a character, right? Like, the queen
of hearts is Queen Elizabeth or
something. Like, who is each character
in the cards deck? So each character in
the card deck becomes a character that
you memorize. So you memorize these 52
cards as people that you know.
And so this is an interesting point also
on the socio dynamics as well as the
spatial dynamics. So each character in
the deck is a person that you know well.
You memorize that 52 people correspond
to these 52 cards, and you know the
layout of your house. So then when you
can go through the order of the deck,
anybody can do it. You can repeat back
the order right away. So, like, you go
through the cards and you say, okay,
you can go through it three or four
times, and then you know the entire
order of the deck of cards. So this is
how to repeat back the order of a deck
of cards just to memorize the order,
like, oh, they're supreme hearts, she's
in a positive, or who's standing in the
doorway is like, the first part, right?
And so, you know the tour through the
house, and you place these people in
this spatial orientation in your house.
And this is like a proven solid way the
people that do these kind of memory
trips use by constructing this memory
house. And I thought that that was super
interesting in relation to this paper,
that memory and planning have evolved
from mechanisms of navigation in the
physical world. And I also wonder if
there is, like, a social role that also
contributes to memory, and could that
social role be this kind of higher
level? Allostasis right, like, we talk
about the homeostat and that's like,
there's no other like, you've got one
time step, right? And then in the out of
step, there's other ways to kind of
modify, but how many in the
social components to succeed and
function and to actively have memory and
prediction? Like, does a tissue have
memory because there's other cells in
the tissue? Does an ant have memory
because it can spatially navigate for
food and also it knows its friends? I'm
sure ants have ways to distinguish one
ant from another ants. Like, they're
very social features. I don't think that
they all think that they're all the
same. Like, my cats don't definitely
don't. My cats know each other. But if
you showed them, like, a stray cat,
they'd be really upset with a stray cat,
I'm sure. So, you know, animals know
each other, I'm sure ants know each
other also. And so what component of
memory is also social? And that just
Jelle me points to help remind me of
that or brought that to, like, sorry if
I have any questions.
Awesome. It brings up a lot of the
aspects that I could add to now just
from a specifically anti perspective.
So you mentioned the evolutionary
aspect. It's one of the themes of the
paper that perhaps from foraging,
but other processes, too, as key
cognitive demands, those early
challenges or, like, ancestral
challenges giving rise to current life
were faced and met in this way. So that
was the evolutionary aspect you
mentioned. And then thinking about the
history at multiple nested scales. So,
like, there's the history of the ant
colony as a genuine modelable
entity, where the colony, year after
year kind of developed in its foraging
territory as its colony personality or
basically phenotype at the colony level
evolve. And then asterisk one
then at the nest mate level, it's the
recent interactions of a nest mate that
induce it to forge locally, meaning
retrieving a seed. So, like, there might
be an ant whose current neural or
hormonal state is such that a lot of
interactions with incoming foragers
don't stimulate more foraging. But then
there might be another ant whose status
is such that a certain reduced rate of
interactions with other foragers, maybe
even no interactions with other foragers
in the entry chamber cause it to go on a
foraging trip. That foraging biology is
specific to this ant shown here, the
harvester ant. But maybe other ants,
too, care that asterisk too. Then
there's the ant tissue. And, like, each
of the ant tissues, the brain, the
different glands, the gut, they're all
undergoing kind of stereotyped
transitions that are called temporal
polyethylem, or they're going through,
like, recent changes, like a leg was
lost and then the least of the body,
like, adaptive. So that's, like, the
history of each nest mate tissue.
The asterisk kind of combined for me
personally, but also just more
conceptually with thinking about the
relational view on modeling the ants,
like, not taking too strong a
view on where phenomena should be
located in terms of nest mate versus
collective cognitive features and then
also the place based and the field and
the long term experiments. So my
advisor, Professor Deborah Gordon, has
done, like, a 30 year plus field study
in Arizona. And so I was doing five
years of fieldwork there, but it was,
like, year, I don't know, 20 something
or 30 something to some other number
five years later in this space where
there was a lot known about this ant
with a long lived colony, but with
turnover of the foragers. And so the
sort of ecological and the place based
nature and then also the specific
biology of this ant where the forager
was just so clearly an expendable part
of the process of the colony, like
sloughed off and some other features of
the foraging biology of these ants.
Pretty interesting system and it reveals
a lot on different cognitive demands and
different foraging environments. So
that's not even getting into the whole
mental foraging or active component,
but just at the ant foraging level.
I think you brought up an important
point, though, Daniel, and I'm not sure
if people associate architecture with
abduction, but your
advisor, supervisor, whatever her title
was, her 30 year window and then
where you stepped in for your five year
window as Nested,
you were the one now Nested within a
larger time frame. So back to Blues
earlier point, but you weren't
historically looking back from the
perspective, okay, here's the
evolutionary nature. You are now seeing
yourself as relative to something that
had a greater timestamp,
right? So you walked into the party and
you had to ask yourself, did these ants
come from this colony? So back to
Perth's, big question of right.
So it's when I come into the situation
that matters as much as if I can induce
a skyscraper or deduce how much
structural rigidity that requires.
Right. So I think this is kind of
interesting now because I'm not sure
if we should assume, like when you were
talking about the phylogenetic trees,
sometimes we just assume we're stepping
in on the
branching, but I'm not sure we should
make that assumption. I think we have to
be careful to be, as you said, very
explicit, not just assumptive of where
we come in in this history. Because if
we don't, we can end up thinking that
this is sort of a linear layering that
figure four, when maybe it's more like
identity. It's both stable and
dynamic.
So it's definitely related to almost the
very first comments of Bleu, like,
where's multiscale identity and
multiscale systems in this hierarchical
depth,
it may be related in some way to
multiscale systems. We could draw that
out. But where is that nesting that
we're describing, the real physical
enclosure sense? And this way
that mental systems can almost be
modeled as Nested, just like we saw
mental action as a nesting of a
cognitive model with an action model
inside of it. It's like the mental
is encoding and even modeling
through inclusion of the Perry personal
space, but then with like a drop off
going further out and then what is that
modeling space? And is
there another operation here? Again,
what are these graphs? What are we
seeing here? Dean, my question is
to answer Blue's question. Do we
get closer to a satisfactory answer by
looking at the mechanics of this or do
we get a better sense of it by seeing
the relationship. Like when you were
explaining the ant part you've spent a
lot of time talking about relationship
and I think maybe one of the things we
try to do is we try to apply the
operation to it when in fact what we
should be doing is seeing the
relationship in its entirety.
I don't want to say zoom out because
you can still zoom out and still get
bogged down in the sequencing because
that's kind of what this does. It says
this layer of sequencing can now build
out, fractal out into these other layers
of sequencing. And I'm suggesting rather
than seeing the layers, maybe it's the
totality of the relationships. I don't
know because Bleu also pointed to the
social piece which is all relationship
all the time, right? So I'm just
wondering if we help ourselves if we
collapse to oh, well, this is now
explainable. Because we have some way of
showing the sequence.
Sometimes that helps, but maybe in this
case it's from an evolutionary
standpoint it doesn't matter whether
we're talking about 1000 years ago and
today as much as the relationship of
what 100,000 years ago and today
represents. I don't know,
just throwing it out there.
Thanks for sharing it. Just one thought
on that and then we'll continue here.
Phylogenetic trees with genomic data are
usually based upon sequence alignment
followed by the fitting of a tree on the
aligned sections of the sequences. And
so there's a lot of ways and approaches
of modeling from the sequence alignment
itself from unaligned to align
sequences, a lot of ways you could do it
and then from the align sequence matrix
to the tree model there's a lot of ways
to do that. It could be a bifurcating
tree, it could be like a different kind
of tree, different algorithms,
Bayesian, et cetera. One interesting
point that many have raised,
but it's very challenging to deal with
is that depending on how stringently you
align the sequences different Ines
with different histories or different
information content partially or in
totality are being filtered out in a
different way. So if you have a mode of
evolution where like short chunks get
interchanged so that locally the
sequences are not changed like domain of
a protein aren't changed but then
they're swapped in order, those might
become nonalignable sequences. And so
the hope is that those kinds of genomic
changes are silent with respect to the
longterm evolutionary history of a
species. But in the short term other
methods might be needed. But in the long
term it's the hope that by pulling back
the alignable sections you can get a
good signal. And so that's a pretty
satisfactory approach when multiple
converging threads do overwhelmingly
agree. But it really shows that when
there's like a signal processing,
filtering and then a model fitting
the information in the data can be
extremely powerfully misleading because
there's so much because you're getting
exactly the same post. Normalized data,
whether it was total noise in,
total bias out or whether your
correction process over normalized for
one thing or another, those are kind of
in that gray zone, unknown, unknown
space coming into the searchlight.
And so there's the whole looking at the
searchlight story. So maybe where do
we situate active inference with respect
to that looking where the light is
searching for one keys, etc. Etc.
Can I just say real quick, I'm not
advocating for don't show your work.
I believe that showing your work really
matters and then when you're trying to
explain what's happening at a certain
point, don't get stuck in,
well, this was the order of the steps
that I took when I showed my work. Try
and zoom out and try and understand what
the relationship as well. That's all
what I'm asking. Does that help being
able to toggle back and forth?
So can I just jump in here for a second
and point out that we had phylogenetic
trees or we had yeah, I guess
they weren't called phylogenetic trees
at the time, but we've had like
speciation trees long before we had
genetics, right? So we can construct
them based on morphometric analysis.
And something that I liked in this paper
is that it really drew out
the affordance of the niche environment
with respect to implication. Because we
saw many instances of species, because
we did these trees when we didn't have
genetic information. And so we had all
of these morphometric characteristics
that we thought were similar. And so we
lumped these species together because
they must be related because they share
this morphometric feature. But in many
circumstances, that was not the case.
And so because of the similarity of the
niche environment or even existing in
the same niche, we had evolution
converge on this feature that was
successful in that environment. And so I
think here the idea of duplication and
the authors got into that, which I
thought was really cool. So the same
mechanism can evolve more than one time
in parallel just because of the fitting
to the niche. Totally agree.
Bleu so when I said multiple conversion
lines of evidence, what I was totally
thinking of was how genomics the
patterns that we get from those aligned
sequences do recapitulate and even
discover unexpected but later verified
relationships. And so that's sort of
like a measure of the unique
explanations and predictions. But this
tree could have been fit with phenotypic
characters, as you mentioned, as it was
for a long time and then it was just a
few sites in proteins and that was sort
of like the 1960s and 70s was fitting
with very reduced data sets and now the
amount of genomic data is rapidly
increasing. But out of the genomics
analysis, the action state of
phylogenetics is really just this tree
topology fit from a family of trees,
hopefully with an uncertainty associated
whether they show it like with a
bootstrap uncertainty or some other way
but then that is an artifact. Now,
there's a few cases where, like, this is
in and of itself interesting, like when
people have resolved some deep
relationships within insects or other
groups and then it helps structure
thinking that can later be brought out
about different traits and ecologies.
But it's like this is just a starting
point for thinking about evolutionary
histories. And like you said, similar
ecological or generative process
processes, dynamics might
beget increase likelihood for a certain
generative model to arise.
And that's like kind of what ecosystem
is like a desert seed harvesting ant
whether it's in the Mediterranean or the
southwest US. Like polka miramax in
the US. And then cataclyphus in
the Mediterranean regions. There's some
similarities there but then there's
other species that are more closely
related that have a different foraging
biology. So then,
how does the foraging strategy sometimes
have extreme fidelity with a group like
leaf cutter ants where once they're
committed to being a full leafcutter
ant, so to speak, evolution or
they haven't been observed to revert
back some other mode versus other,
like, foraging strategies at the group
level, at the colony level. But it's the
individual, in another sense that's like
very interesting thinking about foraging
phenotypes on this tree. And why not?
Just like any other trait that you could
study like the evolution of first
spatial foraging and then the evolution
of cognitive foraging and then applying
that to different search spaces which
was also explored a little in the
citations here the foraging in mind and
foraging and semantic fields papers
what would you say? Bleu? So it's clear
that you brought that up, Daniel. And
just because in our past conversations
you've brought up that the same species
of ants can have different foraging
patterns based upon the colony that they
live in. I think that that's super
interesting and I wonder how could you
map foraging patterns? Like can you put
foraging patterns into a phylogenetic
tree? Is there a tree structure that we
could use to describe foraging patterns
and would that relate to or map onto
this brain structure tree in some way?
There's a lot of diversity within the
same brain structure. Also like the ants
have the same brain structure but even
humans have like some of us go to the
grocery store. Some humans out there are
still like hunting and gathering to
least their food. Awesome Dean,
go for it first so. You guys can
learn me school me on something here.
Is there any evidence that ants all
gather in the morning and the queen
aunt or whatever the organizing and the
principal ant pulls the map out and says
now I kant you to take this thing that
you've mapped and carry it out today.
And I'm not being a smart alec I'm
asking is there some sort of analogous
evidence that they do that?
Okay so to the team
huddle Monday morning stand up.
No, I hope that's not overgeneralizing
because ants are also of course very
diverse in their foraging strategies and
a lot is unknown. But just speaking to
the first approximation the queen is not
a central decision maker in information
router hormonally and at a slower time
scale for sure, but at the behavioral
regulation level. Now in the
morning for the poke and the mirmax they
would like, chill and some would slowly
come out and like their walking speed is
temperature dependent like all insects
and it just assessing maybe the humidity
or damage around the nest entrance. So
there's no reason why those archetypes
like convergence before planning or
rupture repair which of course cannot
have a planning component directly.
Different algorithms are going to have
different levels there.
But because the Kant symbolic
behavior communication is pretty flow
bandwidth probably. So unlike the waggle
dance which is conveying like quite a
lot from an information theory
perspective using symbolic means like
the direction and the distance and also
chemical information like about the
flowers there's ants that like
physically pull another nest mate to a
foraging location. So using memory or
pheromone or like tandem run and there's
probably some limited examples of being
able to do something like a little bit
higher order signaling and also, of
course the smell of the food and the
pheromone and so a lot of the extended
features but they don't
do a powwow with the queen. Okay, so let
me take what you just said and sort of
feedback and maybe build on it a bit.
So you describe the situation. It's
morning if morning then ant behaves like
so and in the last slide of this deck
and the phylogenetic tree you had then
to now or then if. So what I'm wondering
is can we exist in
a sequential world of if then like as a
homeostatic representation is if then
all we need. But if we want to include
temporal depth and hierarchical depth
we actually incorporate the inversion of
that. We incorporate the then if.
Right? So that's my question. So to
Blue's point earlier,
where is this shift or this sense
of what's going on? The relationship
might be the discrepancy.
The first representation figure on the
discrepancy might be those people that
are looking at things from an if then
perspective. If this then we
should expect that from a predictive
standpoint versus the then if
perspective then
the critical call had to be made as the
base runner was foraging for second base
and a call was made. Now if
not a whole bunch of people chime in
about what their interpretation of what
just happened. Right.
So again,
I'm not sure if only looking at it
frontwards and backwards as a sequence
is enough. I think we also have to be
able to see the relationship of if then
and then if from the historical view.
And I think when we do that we go from
architectural existence to architectures
learning.
Okay, let me try to restate that but
I've not lost the forging trail. So if
the outcome is like the end point
then that's
the if then if the person committed the
crime you do the time and then the
sort of then if it precludes if then
in multiple sequences of if then and
uncertainties on if thens and then it
says okay then or it's like if then if.
So we're kind of downtown if and then
that's where the outcome is a starting
point. And so that is in one sense it's
teleological because it's end direct.
Where is this project going to go? Do we
really expect and prefer to publish this
paper on February 28? And then also it
includes the next steps. So it creates a
world model where there is a possible
which is a selectable set of policies
that the team will achieve like that
expected and preferred outcome and then
it sets it up for what would be the
obvious next loop of policy selection.
And so if it's like if things are this
good or bad with the environment in 2030
then this is how much damage will go to
this or this way. Even if you were right
it wouldn't involve the policy selection
elements. And so that's probably a
complex situation with the partitioning
of like estimation and world policy
selection which is clearly a separate
discussion that's dot one being invoked
as an example but it just points to how
those are different components of
inference. And then foraging like an
example of if then and then as if or
then if was like sometimes
the colonies would pack their nest
entrance with pebbles and then there'd
be a thunderstorm in the afternoon. I
don't think a study has ever it's a
totally widely observed behavior with
many animals and there's no exception
with harvester ants. Now maybe there's
thunderstorms where they fail to make
pebbles or it not enough and there's
probably some false positives too. So we
don't really know the exact success
ratio. Maybe it's better than the
previous days forecast, maybe it's
worse. But it's very clear to see that
the nest mate doesn't need to have been
inheriting from its evolutionary history
and its niche rain cloud modeling
software. It's just picking up pebbles
with a activity to interactions and
humidity etc. That help colonies that
have that proclivity succeed in that
niche. Which doesn't even mean that it
was a popular phenotype like 20 years
ago as things change in a region.
So that's like super interesting.
Let's return to foraging and the
foraging variation question. But first,
let's see if we've completed the figure
four discussion. And just
like, is there anything else we want to
add about, like the main? Because this
is kind of what the paper works towards.
And then there's, like, a little
downhill role is, like, we could do this
algebra on the free, but this is sort of
where things get led up to through
demonstration of the motifs and the
connection between cognition and
structures and structured learning and
then, like, parameter learning at a
behavior or developmental time scale and
then structure changes over evolutionary
active states. So we have hierarchical
depth, temporal depth, which we're also
just kind of adding in a spatial
component allostasis which was used
in the paper with the intermodality.
But maybe it could be other modalities
or same. There's duplication, which is
kind of like parallelization that's like
adding another nest mate or another unit
to the compound eye of insect
developmentally. And then I
is homeostasis, which is being used here
as sort of the base or
root or ancestral case which is
referring at the behavior time scale to
return to a stable point. And then also
at the more evolutionary time scale,
the eye operator on the homeostat, it's
like the homeostasis on homeostasis.
It's keeping the structure of that model
fixed. And then when the homeostasis at
the evolutionary time scale is open then
the structural transformations here are
like the affordance from that base case,
which is what's being shown, like, with
the main one on the left being broken
into these. And then each of these
become the prior for each of these next
ones.
Anything to add before we go to forging?
No. Okay, no.
Great relevant question.
Bleu measuring foraging. So one paper,
though, there's a bunch that are really
relevant, but Michelle Dean 2014 did
a lot of literature review and
visualizations of foraging strategies in
different ant species. So these are like
some of the foraging approaches, like
foraging archetypes and then
categorized those into different
traits on a tree.
So that's an awesome work and something
that could and should be extended and
integrated with like, modern databases
so that somebody could submit, we just
saw this one going in a trail. And then
that kind of reduces our uncertainty
about a broader model of ant
foraging because it's like, oh, that's a
surprising conversation about this given
what we already knew about that species,
for example. But how do you actually
measure foraging variation within or
across the species? So in this case,
in figure one, these are like kind of
like the structure at
one level, they're like archetypes of
structure. Now, sometimes they probably
blur within each other. Like, if it's
two, then it's tandem running. But if
it's three, is it a group or is it still
like pseudo tandem running? You know,
so it could be a little blurriness. And
also, there could be different modes
even within the same species or like in
a continuum between a foraging column
with, like, a trunk and a spread versus
like, just a spread. So this is sort of
like I've. Dot two, jump in and say,
like, how these look like neurons just
with different axons and dendritic
fibers. These are like different brain
structures. So I just had to point that
out. Yeah, the bottom one definitely
does. Even both of these and even this
top one too, the trunk trail.
Let's just say that these are sort of
architectures within a broader space and
then within a given mode,
then the behavior ecological will tend
to make like a more specific measure.
So let's just say it's 100% a trail
forger. Then having the counts to
and from on the trail is a good measure.
So like in the harvest ranks they most
basically do this trunk trail on the
top. So there would be like one or two
or three main avenues that they were
leaving the colony in for that day and
then sometimes it be the same day to
day, other times it would be slightly
different. But then what happens when
one wanders off not on a trail? Is it
still a forager? And a lot of that
space is really interesting. But suffice
to say that once a foraging definition
has been selected, like not just the
class that it's going to be, but also
how it's gain to be measured in that
study, then there can be like
quantitative parameter comparisons like
this colony foraged at this rate in
terms of number of outgoing foragers per
minute. And then its neighboring colony
of the same species was doing at this
rate. So you can do like parameter
comparisons within the species kind of
at the population level. And then there
might be another ant species whose
activity it doesn't really make to
compare because it's like a different
number of nest mates, it has a different
foraging ecology. So that's kind of
where the structure learning would come
into play with comparing the ants that
are encoding the scale, insects versus
foraging for seeds versus doing whatever
else they do. And then within a species
or perhaps across a few species that
have a similar foraging ecology, it's
possible to do parametric comparisons.
So I have a question for you Daniel.
How does foraging fit architecture?
What do you think? No, I Dean, I'm not
trying to be a smart allocator. I'm
really curious because most
architectural analogies result in some
sort of an outcome that's static. Like
there's a lot of processing that went
into the outcome but the outcome is
static. And I don't think that any of
the representations in the frame that
you're moving right now, although the
differences are appear as static,
they're supposed to be representing
something that's quite dynamic. So
that's where the question of the
architectures piece blended with
evolution might be helpful or
it might be oxymoronic depending upon
how you interpret it. Right.
Architecture implies like there's an
architect. I don't know, in an
evolutionary sense I'm not sure like
architecture is the right word. It's
weird. Yeah, but I'm not saying it's
wrong. I'm just saying you have to be
really careful and then what assumptions
you come in with based on what you think
architecture is. Yeah, maybe you're
thinking of the way I am. I'm not saying
it's wrong, I'm just saying, what
baggage does that carry? When we're
talking about something that's actually
quite dynamic.
You can see the ants and the ant. Hill
has an architecture. Yes, you can take a
snapshot of it, but is that what we're
really talking about when we're talking
about foraging? So what's the
difference between a structure and an
architecture? I wonder that. Yeah.
It'S just semantics. Yeah, I think it's
more than that. But we just have to be
careful that we don't insert
one for the other, thinking that they're
the same thing. That's what the whole
ontology exercise is about. I mean, I
got my mind changed. Okay. Normally I'm
the one that argues that don't give
somebody an owner's manual. Get them
behind the wheel, right? They'll see
their owner's manual later. But in this
particular case, I'm kind of going,
wait a second, we better all agree what
we're talking about. So here it is.
What's the difference between structure
and architecture? Structure tends to be
the pieces and the parts of the design
and how it goes together and the
finished object. Architecture defines
how the final object looks, behavior and
costs by designating, how design choices
are made. So architecture implies that
there's some kind of agency behind the
design. And that was kind of my
interpretation of it also. Okay.
Bunch of stuff. There that last point,
like the definition of architecture
involves the choices rather than
structure involving just the description
of parts. So that's kind of like the
perception, variational, free energy.
That's like structure.
It also means the entire thing. So it's
not just the parts, it also means the
entire object. Yes, but it still doesn't
involve preferences or choices. It's
about description, like perceptual
processing is. And then the
architectural definition has choices in
it and then that is what you brought to
like agency and also architecture.
It's like a profession and an
operational approach to modeling the
process of building and building,
though there's probably theoretical and
basic architectures and all this other
stuff. Okay, we're just a few thoughts
here on like the engineering and
designing. So I guess one ontology that
can be helpful here is with Bucky Fuller
talking about structural integrity,
which is something that has static
holding strength, like a metal cube has
static holding strength. Then there's
process or the pattern integrity, which
is sort of like describing the life
cycle of the butterfly and the
caterpillar, like a recapitulation of
process. And that is
a lot more like this sort of dynamic
systems approach to organization
rather than the build it and block it
approach because these multiscale
systems always have things that are
turning over at different timescales.
And then there's just so many mechanisms
that that can be modeled by or actually
occurs by. Like just in the harvester
ants. It's the historiosity of that
colony over the years, then the nest
mate and that day. And it's visual
memory and just how many factors come
into play then every foraging trip at
the nest mate level could be seen as
unique and the exact communication will
just never be recapitulated. Some of the
major ones can be explore and then
controlled for, tested for in a lab.
But that's part of the openendedness of
dynamics systems because by changing the
setting, you can study certain features.
But then it's another step that's
impossible in practice to understand how
those features that were in a different
environment translate to the first
environment. So you can take the
essential behavior of the traffic jam
and then recapitulate it with the
simulation and the lab experiment and
all this. But it's a different thing to
actually put it into the design time,
which is happening at a different time
scale than just building the skyscraper
and leaving it there. But that's more
like the dynamic organism.
So where's foraging on this?
And I would ask, is there a different
kind of forging? If we're talking about
sort of the sort of the machine learning
type of foraging on this versus the wet
foraging of an ant,
can we actually see those two things
being quite different in terms of how
those two foraging types plays out? Or
do we focus on the things that are
different about those two things? Or do
we focus on the things that are the same
about those two types of foraging?
Bleu also with your foraging from a more
culture and human perspective,
social machine learning and foraging.
So machine learning and foraging,
I've done some modeling of foraging
with, like, agency modeling. But in
machine learning, I wonder, like,
I mean, I know that there's information
forging but that's usually explore from
the human concept, right? Like humans
going out and looking for information
and how long we stay on the website.
And so but I
wonder about machine learning and neural
networks doing object classification.
Is there a foraging that they do there?
Like, you know, they pick up things
like, Chris Ola wrote
a really awesome publication about how
we understand how neural networks work.
And they kind of deconstruct a deep
dream that's onto Still Club, which is
really cool. It was like a 2018 paper.
But they look at how does a neural
network recognize a dog,
a dog in a tennis ball? So they look for
like, round object and like, you know,
floppy ear. So there's like different
neurons in the neural network that'll
learn what is a floppy ear or learn what
is like a round object. And so it's this
combination of different things that the
neural network learns that piece
together to form. Like, this is a dog
with a tennis ball, which is a super
interesting way to think about it. And I
wonder, in training a neural network,
can that be looked at as a type of
information foraging, right? Like the
network is setting out to learn distinct
pieces of a pattern that it'll later
piece together to make it complete image
recognition. So it's
interesting. I'll give a
thought on the machine learning and the
bio origin. So you mentioned
there's the question of should we
approach it from a similarities or a
different perspective? And there's
different reasons why you might approach
different angles. Right. Like what is
the most pedagogical to someone learning
about the difference versus what is the
best way to approach this to a certain
stakeholder, who is actually applying
this question in a certain context? But
to get to the question outside of that,
the idea of contrast came to mind
because we recently had the model stream
on contrastive Active Inference, which
used machine learning. So check out that
stream, but it involved a contrasting
step of processing inputs before doing
policy selection, etc. So that helps
scenes that are broadly similar but have
a key difference that's small, like
where the ping pong ball is can be
learnt better because there's a
contrasting and that reminds me of
language learning when it's like here's
and here's and then that's a contrast
that isn't going to come up in the
language, but then it helps learn on
that. And that's not just a machine
learning thing because even in the
parametric modeling of SPM,
statistical parametric modeling mapping,
but the model making of it,
the contrast matrix is the experimental
design. And so if it's just condition A
and cognition B and you have ten
measurements, it's just five of a five
zeros and five ones. And that's like the
true or false matrix that basically gets
multiplied to do statistics on. So
whether it's a very classical,
parametric, sparse modeling approach,
which was initially all that was had by
statisticians, or whether it is now
things that are highly parametric,
or just all this other stuff with modern
machine learning, the contrast is like
this key piece because it's always about
what signals being detected within a
data set and then also how the
difference between that examples and the
population is being modeled. And so like
in parametric statistics that's about
the sample standard deviation. And then
there's a slightly different equation
for, like, the population standard
deviation if you would have kept on
sampling. And then it's also sometimes
hard to incorporate that kind of
reasoning into these more modern
statistical systems where it's, like,
very easy to overfit because there's a
lot of data, but it's hard to model how
that large chunk of data is related to
even other segments of data. So it's
similar to the phylogenetic challenge.
But that is one that is like searching
for contrast. Takes on a very different
meaning.
But how is it related to foraging?
There's the info foraging like Bleu
mentioned. There's the path element of
foraging which might be related to
inferring the best info foraging path
for somebody on their feed because it
has to balance the Epistemic and the
Pragmatic. Or at least it acts as if it
balances the Epistemic and the
Pragmatic. So foraging could be
maybe looked at in that way.
I think what this slide represents is
broadly speaking, not just or broadly
identity. I think what we do
is in that diagram, we tend to
differentiate. We see the levels because
we've created the partitions.
We see the dependencies because over on
the far left we have actually Bleu
arrows that show what those dependencies
are and then we reintegrate,
right? I remember when I was doing my
I come back to the program that I was
doing, but I would say to the kids, I
mean, there's a migration piece to this
that we have to develop, which I would
consider to be the tactics, which would
include foraging. And then there's a
tools use or a strategy piece, which is
sort of the information covered as
changed as measured, which is kind of
the instrument piece. And what I kept
saying to them was you kind of need to
have both all the time. You don't need
to know the difference between something
that's a migration or an action
or a fulfillment in the sort of the
physical space and the tools sort of the
thinking instrumental parts where you
can turn what you're seeing into these
models and these representations. You
have to kind of be able to marry the two
of them all the time. You have to be
able to integrate them across these
boundary when you're trying to get into
these professional settings. Now, that
isn't a construction exercise. That's
being creative because you really don't
know at the end of the day how it's
going to turn out. But the big point
that we were trying to make was don't
leave one of those two things behind.
Like don't get stuck because you can't
go out and forage don't get stuck
because you don't think you can draw the
perfect representation of the world.
It's just an instrument, right? I mean,
even a spoon can eventually drain an
ocean if you're prepared to spend enough
time on it. So I think that's what this
representation I think that's one of the
greatest gifts of this representation
is. It kind of lays out very clearly
that there's two parts to this. How do
we differentiate eventually
on different duplication,
parallelization dependency
predictability, preferential time
based and spatial based and then scale
based and then reintegrate it all back
together into some sort of a coherency?
For some people, though, I think it's
kind of dense. I mean, if you walked in
today, gee, I don't know what kind of
prerequisites you would need, what kind
of priors you would need to understand
what the heck we're talking about. But
as I said, for me, the entry point, the
lowest level, was do you migrate? Do you
tool use? Most people already admit they
can find examples when they do both. So
my question then would be, so will you
know that you're doing both going
forward? And if you can do that, maybe
it's not quite. So quite so dense
or quite so mystifying.
So a few things. There so great
point that going foraging on your merry
way without having all hidden states
learnt at the structural level or
the parametric level, even conditioned
on a structure. So you don't even know
what's out there. No cognitive agent
does. And at the structural and the
parametric level, the inference
challenge is about action selection
under uncertainty of multiple types.
The inference challenge is of action
having subproblems involving inference
on perception and causal modeling. But
those are like little subproblems within
a broader frame that active inference
provides of like action prediction,
action on policy selection. And then
foraging is a great setting to study
policy selection. And then you brought
up like that. There's prerequisites that
we hope to learn what different
backgrounds can come to active inference
from. But I think one takeaway from the
paper would be that perhaps archaic
in a foraging structure,
whatever that means. But the way that we
forage through linguistic and idea space
and solution space, strategy space can
be modeled by some graph motifs and
classes and transformations, which is
what the contribution of this paper is.
And they also describe some of the more
basal or homeostatic ancestral
structures. So it's like you have a
linear model that works for height data
and it works for weight data and it
works for height and weight together.
It's just any numbers you pass to the
linear model, the GLM, it's going to be
basically okay, this is like another
model class that can take or apply to
cognitive modeling, homeostatic
modeling, cognitive and homeostatic
modeling, all these variations that are
being described here. So that's just one
way to put it with perhaps fewer
prerequisites. And then these were
interactions questions. Is this what it
was? Do you migrate and do you use
tools? Yeah. So when
you're talking about tools, are you
talking about provisions? And especially
if you come to breakfast with a plan on
how to build a spoon, how is that going
to help you eat your cereal when your
foraging exercise was to be able to move
the cereal from the bowl into your
mouth? Right? So lots of times,
especially in some of the more
conventional ways we look at things, we
tend to take the plan to the cereal
bowl instead of the actual spoon. So the
provisioning part is more than a plan,
it's more than the words and it's more
action oriented representation. It's the
actual implements that we carry with us
when we do that migration that I think
really counts. Because if you carry, I
guess you can origami a sheet of paper
into a spoon, but then that's
another process that you have to go
through. But really what you wanted was
just to have the implement.
So when you talk about migration,
how far is a migration? Like if you're
a single cell organism, like migrating
through the ocean.
Maybe the migration in that case is
moving around. You right. You don't have
to think migration in terms of me from A
to B. If I'm stationary and A to B are
passing by me when
the car beside me is pulling out of the
learning lot, I feel like I'm moving
forward. Right. That's also a migration.
So that is related to what
we talked about with some of the
geometry, like the projective geometry
and how there's the flipping between the
egocentric geometric projection where
it's like your peri personal space and
it's kind of like a distribution around
you. Like there's me in the center or
located somewhere. And then there's
like, things closer to the eyes are
generated to be bigger because they
don't leave to be because we know we're
making the generative model anyway. So
why does it happen? Why can't I see it
from Grand Theft Auto perspective? It is
a certain way for a certain reason. So
then that is flipping.
That's flipping with the more,
like objective or D personalized
stance, like the prior on the
architecture structurally in my room
with a right angle. And even if it looks
different than a 90 degree angle in the
generative models, that's perceived as
normal or unsurprising because it's
compatible with the underlying
structural hypothesis that's unobserved.
And then the observed structural
observation that has to do with the
actual way that the angles look.
So here's just one other kind of
Professor Gordon shout out angle to look
into evolution of algorithms for
collective behavior. So let's connect
this to the cognition foraging
and then Dean's questions. Do you
migrate? Do you use tools? And do you
provision? So that's like related
questions. So that one might be like,
how do you adapt when things change and
you can't adjust certain things. Or also
the difference between, like, let's just
say I'm using a software I'm not very
familiar with, like Photoshop between
doing one move photoshop searching on
the search engine. How do I paste okay,
paste. Okay, I do one move. So it's like
a one step model of function versus
someone who just rolls out of bed,
opens up Photoshop, and then they just
open their mind to being creative and
being in feedback with what they
actually do. And maybe that does involve
still using a search engine, but they're
in a functional flow with respect to
that tool and they've just set aside the
time so that their regime of attention
can be, like, productive or aligned with
a project. But they're not going step by
step. They're engaged in broader
organization.
So we're talking about figuring out part
rather than the finding out. That's what
you just described the difference
between those two things. Yeah. Opening
space for figuring out, for figuring
out. And that's sort of like it's
a little bit like local and more measle,
or global foraging, which is like you
can dig in a given patch of dirt, so
it's super labor intensive. But it's a
local finding of what is there versus
trying to find a better Dutch of dirt
and dig their first seed, maybe even
find an exposed seed. But whether one of
those policies has a higher risk of
reward or energy expenditure that's gain
to depend a dot one what one believes
about the frequency of like half emerged
seeds and seeds in this location and the
time cost of moving from location to
location. There's just a ton of features
and it's not just like as simple as
making a heat map of where the seeds
are.
We would describe it as mimic foraging
and mimic foraging and what
was the other one modify foraging.
Some people might believe that for it.
So it's interesting at active inference
I was at last week, they talked about
how far can you get mimicking an expert
and there were several talks. So whether
it's navigating a maze or figuring
out whatever so like they'll train a
model on a whole bunch of expert, what
would an expert do? And then they set
them loose in like a novel circumstance
and if the novel circumstance is similar
enough, it kind of works. But really,
like, the better thing to do is to put
some exploratory components in there so,
you know, you have, like, the expert
training. But if there's an explorer
component about, that doesn't leave to
do with an expert or, like, you know,
if you train it to navigate its own
maze, also sometimes, like, alternating
with its own maze or image with experts
in it. So like following the experts
only gets you so far. And I wonder, and
something that's come to really mean a
lot to me in the field of intelligence
is when there's information.
Like when you can do something new,
when you can generative, model, solve
any image because you learning from a
few experts that's innovative or the
ability to generalize, but also the
ability to innovate and produce some new
output rather than just do what the
experts do.
So one thought that's awesome.
Comments Bleu like learning from
examples and from experts usually
learning by example when used not in a
malicious way is referring to seeing
somebody who is better or least
adequate, if not far, far better.
And then there's this question of like
should it be shown only at the expert
level? Because the expert speaker
would do tongue twisters and Russian
sentences with five conjugations. But
the expert in interaction is able to
approach a zone of agreement and of like
proximal development so that the example
and the expertise as applied is in a
very specific space and that's like the
order of examples and then knowledge
this person is able to conjugate this
thing. But they're having challenge in
conjugating this case. So then depending
on their personality, maybe you lean
more on the one that they are more
familiar with or maybe they come to you
to be wrong. So there's a lot of
advanced cognitive modeling and
parameters that could be in a
fullfledged model because that's a super
complex scenario, especially in a group
and all of these relationships on
relationships. And we
don't need to have that whole generative
process model to have a generative model
of policy that can be effective at
foraging in that space. So it
is a project and making that map
is helpful for it. But to make policy
decisions in the cognitive space isn't
the same as describing and mastering all
the variables of the cognition process.
And so this mental foraging and physical
foraging and also what we talked about
with a sensory motor detachment helps
make that really clear.
How does active inference model
relevant expertise,
whether domain expertise or discipline,
like a set of affordances A versus a
whole different set of affordances, you
know, B or expertise
like in that language learning example
or some other example where it's not
simply about providing some advanced
example and then having people asymptote
to that. It's about opening the space
for figuring out in that setting.
I think you can find a structural
adaptation in mimicking an expert and
that typically sort of plays itself out
as instructionalism. I think you can
find yourself also modifying
your niche and adapting in that way and
then being able to go back and have an
expert look at what you've done. And the
reason why they're an expert in that
particular case isn't because you're
going to mimic them, but because you're
going to ask them what they Hohwy,
the process that they use to arrive at,
where they have a certain subject
confidence. They are able to now
diagnose where your confidences
might exist and where you might want
to might want to re examine what
the probabilities and preferences were
that got you to the conclusions that you
drew. So again,
you're going to adapt either way. But I
think that the path that you choose
matters and knowing which path that you
chose also matters. So I adapted,
right? I adaptive because I'm now
trained up to be able to find the Bleu
dot, the Bleu ball in the sea of
plastic balls, right? That's one form of
adapting because I've never been in a
ball pit before and now I found the one
that I was looking for. But another
person could go in there and be able to
maybe do something else with that Bleu
ball because they modified the frame and
the mesh and that's that.
Again, we just want to make sure that we
know that there's a difference so that
when we are reintegrating them at some
point in the future, we know how we got
there. That's all.
Okay.
I like the throwback to instructionalism
and interactionism. It's an example. It
was like latently there when talking
about that niche dependence and the
cocreation. So all these kind of terms
digital stigma, g when working online,
for examples, become implicit when we're
using a given sequence to be talking
about like a certain thing that we want
to call our attention to. We call our
attention to some example or to some
relationship and then that modifies our
cognition model so that we're thinking
about things and doing things
differently after. And so it's kind of
like quality of engagement rather than
quantity because some people by
reading a little, change a lot and vice
versa try to set up the relationship. I
think it's funny that you bring up
learning. So for a very long time
my PhD advisor never read anything.
She would never read anything. Did she
read it? She does like
speed reads. She's speed reads, right?
Which means she looks at every third
word and then when she really sits down
to read it, she's got all these things
to say about it and wants to like, you
know, wordsmith every sentence and it's
great. We've had a lot of fun working
together. I don't mean to make that
sound evil in any way, I don't speed
read. I read fast. But I'm totally
incapable of speed reading because I
feel like I have to duplicate my
efforts. Like if I skim it like I can
pick up some headings or whatever but I
never really dot two read it. If I kant
to read something, I want to really read
it, like go through it line by line by
line and look up things, I don't know
what they mean and this kind of thing.
So it's a different and interesting
approach how different people approach
things in different ways.
Yeah, you know, talking about in
this paper how we've been going
between the sort of physiological and
biological substrate of cognition and
the nervous system and the brain and all
of that. And then this more cognition
modeling approach which can be sort of
cut and dry or overly computational or
so called unrealistic with respect to
biological foundations. It's kind of
like what Dean pointed to is like the
bifurcation and so now things are kind
of coming together,
not in the way that everyone might have
expected, but at least in a way and
so that's a very interesting space and
then Bleu with a fast and slow reading.
It's almost like there are multi
scale dynamics associated with attention
that can be measured with the EEG but
it's a hidden state what is actually
happening in the mind and brain. But
those are the kinds of experiments that
people use. And there's some rhythms
like the fast cycles, like gamma that
are playing out at the speed of
perception and awareness of words.
And then there's also slower symbolic
or. Semantic changes in all these
different timescales and it's just like
making the space to least the
connections and the terms and the
implication resonate and connect
with the learner and the creator is like
a lot more valuable than any amount of
coefficient of low reading. And so
how to balance the information amount
and type and sequence and all of these
things with holding the space for
just a slower transformative process.
And that's very true. Yeah, that's huge,
Daniel, because I think a lot of people
that get into the instructionalism,
you'll hear the expression and I'm not
overgeneralizing here, you'll hear,
Jelle, we're going to break this down,
as opposed to the interactionism,
which is, we're going to slow this down.
There's quite a difference between those
two things. Open up and slow down, or
we're going to drill down, finish it
out, get it done in the time. And as we
discuss, like, this is the archetypes or
the dialectic. It's not like we're only
taking one approach or another. But it's
very easy to see how the range in at
least education space, not even thinking
of other areas, is like, it's the amount
of content and then it projects down
into how it's delivered and then content
gets slotted in or out, or things get
expanded or not. Or the Monday's class
gets canceled and it moves to Tuesday.
So that's like the sort of instruction
projection approach which is so
exafferent in multiple ways,
especially in how it's applied to
thinking more about the opening up a
space and slowing down and the learner's
journey and all that. And when
you're in the huddle and you're calling
out the shorthand before you actually
line up at the scrimmage line and snap
the football, it's interesting. That
what you point out, Lou. In my history,
I was always prepared to slow down when
it was math and the symbology. Like, I
have no problem slowing down for that.
But trying to read out long sentences,
it just about kills me. I mean, my Add,
I have to interleave like every 20 to 30
minutes because if I don't, my skin
starts to crawl. Those sort of
contextual factors that are literally
weighing on you, you don't know those
sorts of things. And if you're an expert
who's just trying to push out all this
information in a 13 week window, I'm not
really sure whether or not you can sort
of get down to that level of
personalization. But if you're able to,
it makes all the difference in the world
in terms of what people take away from
the exposure. Right. I find it way
easier to do the shorthand thing. If a
picture is worth 1000 words,
I'm in full agreement with that. I just
can't do the thousand word thing.
Yeah, really interesting. And Steven
wrote in the Chat, good to see these
questions about active modeling
expertise being thought of in different
ways, like the direction of travel, the
distance to travel, the rate of travel,
mode of transport.
Yeah, thanks for sharing it, Steven.
Landscapes and sort of the sense making
and the way finding and being on this
cognitive landscape versus or and being
on this spatial foraging landscape. So
going out for the mushroom forage with
someone who's familiar with mushrooms
and somebody else who's familiar with
the biochemistry but hasn't seen the
mushroom in the ground. And then someone
else who's on a different perspective
because of their background or people
with different physical abilities and
knowledge in the spatial setting. And
then there's the cognitive foraging.
And then just like, is it that the
colony forages as a unit, and then
that's the sort of flip side of the nest
mate's forage collectively. And so the
team forges as a unit collectively.
And the individual is sort of engaged at
this level that we have experience at
in the policy selection relevant to our
participation in some either
niche or team or project.
Let's go back to paper, see if there's
any other pieces that we could kind of
look at. Let's look at the roadmap.
Can we talk a bit about the endowment
part of this? We haven't really touched
on that. Well, just the endowment.
What's the endowment? So in the .2s,
essentially, now that we've built this
base, a stable platform, what can we
do with it? Like, what leverage have we
now potentially active? So what's the
endowment here in terms of what the
paper really? What's the new affordances
that we didn't have before that we
didn't maybe necessarily have explicated
quite so clearly prior to reading the
paper? Maybe that's one. I don't want to
put pressure on Bleu, but what do you
think? Bleu? So I'm trying to remember.
Maybe you guys can remind me in this
figure. Oh, wait, so endowing with
temporal depth. It's got to be an
autostap, right? Is that correct?
Yeah, because endowing a homeostat with
temporal data isn't possible, right? Or
they can only do and I
wonder if that's like, a singlecelled
organism can only do at that moment.
Like they're not planning for it to get
cold later or something like that.
I wonder if it's not only temporal
depth but any kind of relationship. I
wonder if it's not necessarily temporal
depth. It's time. It's flat. Right?
I mean, I guess in order to modify your
own behavior or thought, you would have
to have some temporal depth. But this
allostasis idea is interesting
with respect to my relationship to
my future self or my relationship to my
previous self or my relationship to
other people in my community or
whatever. So I just wonder
about if that's why this
is the allocate and not the homeostat.
Or like, can you endow the homeostatic
temporal depth and get that same kind of
ability for perspective and
retrospective inference? You can't, but
why not? Maybe let's put some words to
that. Let me see if I can find some of
the paper. Nice point.
I would say homeostatic function could
be in a model with memory or
anticipation. Like, the thermometer
could record the last 100 time points,
or it could have a prediction for the
next 100. But the function would be that
it only turns on the heating once it
gets too cold. So it still is the on
the action selection side. It still is
making one Markov chain decision based
upon an instantaneous measurement.
And so it can be implemented whether
just for a computational parsimony or in
a simple biological system with just one
time step. If it's this hot, then turn
on the cooling. It's the ultimate if
then because it's like a threshold model
and so it gets pared down over
evolutionary time. But then you're
bringing up like to even engage with a
counterfactuals or some influence or
something on future policy, there has to
be like a depth. And then
this gets back to whether it's modeling
the thing itself. Like what
do these represent? Are they the
scientists testing a model of one, two,
three or four five hour temporal depth
for the ant forager? Or is this the
forager's quote, cognition model, as if
that were somehow not modelbased
science? Or is it the neural
architecture or the functional anatomy
of the forager? There's a
lot of ways it could lean or be framed,
I think, in a complementary way.
But one will have to be really careful
where support for one domain super valid
and where is one not? Like if it
were a circuit board with that topology,
then it seems like pretty good to go to
use that as a pretty broad descriptor
of the system. Whereas if this was a
simplification of memory and there was
an uncertainty parameter labeled
uncertainty or anxiety, like we
discussed a little earlier, someone
slaps a parameter on one of these edges
and starts addressing complex real world
settings. How does that exactly work?
So one of the things that I think that
it endows us with is that the homeostat
is the basic pattern.
There's a partition between the epsilon
and the mu. So the first thing that they
did is they created a sort of horizontal
partition and then when they went to the
parallelism, now there's two epsilons
and two muse. And so now they added the
vertical partition as well. And I think
that's really, really helpful in terms
of at the basic level of the statistical
we talked last time that you leave to
kind of be a polymath. But I think from
a modeling perspective it's getting that
orthagonal mesh established that
moves us up the chain of complexity
because then all of a sudden you can
have diagonal dependencies and
then you can actually add the z plane
going through this in terms of how the
scale is built out on both distance and
time. So I think that's one of the
endowments that it provides.
I could just restate that it's like when
we say that one of the advantages
potentially in application of active
inference could be that models are
composable, so they can be composed
within a given scale, like spatially or
temporally, and that has a visual
representation. It can also be composed
in this nested way, which as we've
explore several times can represent
physical enclosure or temporal
enclosure, as well as this cognitive
architecture, like mental action,
depending on how different variables are
interpreted in nested modeling. And so
it's composable in several dimension of
transformation which they represented in
Figure Four in a way where each
transformative step, even though the
function might change a lot from the
beginning to the end. Each
organizational or structural
architectures, cognitive, step or
morphological, if one is looking at that
layer, can be mapped into
a certain space and direction of
movement within that space. Do you think
it can also be sculpted out? I mean,
because we're looking at this
historically, we're looking at all the
things that happened in the history.
Was this the stuff that was kind of
carved out? And a lot of the stuff that
doesn't matter removed in order for it
to be more comprehensible, because I
agree with you, it can be composed. But
I also think it's not decomposed. But I
do think or even deconstructed, I think
it can be sculpted out of a greater
history. A greater whole.
Yes, please. Sorry.
When you talk about a greater history,
when you talk about historicity in
today, like during the last few hours,
and we've also talked about memory, and
there's a difference, right? So
historicity is like, historically
accurate and memory is like what
I remember or what any individual
remembers. Yeah, we've talked about that
before, actually, I have, a few
livestreams ago. All I'm thinking is
that what this does is compare all the
things that is an Axle constant that
said, how did he frame it so that we
can understand why we're here now versus
all the things that didn't make it
right. That's essentially what I'm
talking about in terms of explaining.
Right. They're explaining why something
got to the place that it did, as opposed
to the necessity of all the things you
had to do, all the things you had to
compose in order to realize I'm trying
to bring that back to a sculpting
metaphor now. Awesome. So that's
the actual constant 2021 paper. The
title was the Free Energy Principle.
It's not about what it takes. It's about
what took you there. That's definitely
an evolution perspective. And it's
partially because of Axel's background
in evolution and ecology, because that's
what we can say about evolution. This is
what got birds here. Right? And so
the counterfactuals in evolution are a
really interesting topic and that's sort
of explored in a variety of
more popular as well as more
mathematical treatments, like how do we
go from the observed, which must have
existed? So it's very easy to fall to
them being the best of all possible
worlds, optimal form, etc. But then we
also recognize the changing environments
and interactions and all that. And then
Bleu, like with the historicity facts
and the impacts, which are like facts
that aren't known. And then there's the
memory, which requires a perspective.
People could use system memory or
something to refer to a factor and
impact on a system. But these are just
being used loosely like some parts of
how the past influence the present and
the future have to do with systems that
take a perspective. Other impacts are
not through those adaptive active
inference agents. And so that's very
different. And so historicity is kind of
like the stigma g pheromone layer and
then there's like memory with the
forager. So you could talk about the
memory of the ground for the pheromone,
but it makes sense to just remember that
it's a different thing with the
pheromone on the ground than the
cognitive infra ant. And no
nest may is going to have all the
knowledge or the onboard modeling to
make decisions safer. The ones that dot
two complicate it too much, but it's
stuck in the dialectic between doing
exactly what worked in the least, which
is to say recently succeeded, but might
not work in the future and changing
things. But once you move into changing
things, the space of the adjacency of
changing is sometimes like daunting and
you still haven't really address the
problem of changing world. So origin
is a very deep entry point into a lot of
these questions in active inference and
in other areas because it really
connects to the egocentric,
hopefully not in the Solop cystic or
narcissistic sense, but just in the
wayfinding sense making paradigm
that actually accommodates for others
through modeling them explicitly and
prioritizing the environment and things
like that. So pretty cool.
And this paper just to kind of restate
what they brought to the picture,
they looked at evolutionary time scales
and they framed cognition as structural
change, which in a Bayesian modeling
framework is sometimes called structural
learning as opposed to like parameter
learning, fine tuning given the model
structure. And they connected that
to the Bayesian graph model of active
inference lab partitioning and then
connected that to the factor graphs and
then using the homeostat example,
talked about how there could be like
elaborations into other structures.
So from structures to each other that
might be enabling the rise of phenotypes
or enabling the modeling of phenotypes
that are interesting.
Okay, any final thoughts are like,
where does this tape take us? What is
exafferent now? What are we going to be
talking about soon?
So I'm excited to really delve into the
math that is going to get behind
the models that were elucidated out in
figure four. How do we go through
time and through relationality and
hierarchical dimensions and so forth?
Okay. Thank you. Bleu Dean. You won't
have the least word, but what do you
think?
Jelle I'm still trying to figure out how
this sort of ties in with the whole
identity piece. I left that because I
thought that was just a rabbit hole that
went way too far and too deep. But I
know that when you do get that
parallelism and when you. Can sort of
create a dimensional grid that has a
negative space as well. So like, you can
be as units going positively or
negatively and passing through zero and
how that fits with identity. That's kind
of a personal thing that I got to do.
The other thing the thing that I really
liked about this paper is that I think
it took something that's really, as you
said, over huge timescales and sort
of took it back down to something that
might be digestible for a lot of people
that otherwise they kind of go okay, so
here's 1000 years ago or a million years
ago or whatever. From the bacteria to
now. What are the sort of basic
building blocks that we say might have
might have played Hae Park in getting
to the kind of sophistication where we
are now? And again, I think it's about
learning. I always think that evolution
is about learning. And so,
as I said in the .1, this affirmed a lot
of the stuff that I think we need to be
bringing into some of the more formal
ways that we structure learning because
I think it's learning sort of unleashed
as opposed to all tied up.
Awesome. Thanks both and everybody who
was helping in all the ways for the
previous videos. Just some last thoughts
would be like from both of you and
hopefully all together. There's really
some interesting insights into learning
and education for active inference
learning, which is kind of like our meta
regime of attention active inference lab
lab when we're in that regime of
attention. But many people have other
regimes of attention where it would
certainly apply to bring some
of these methods and ideas in and also
bring pieces from outside into our
cognitive modeling of attention and
collaboration and communication. Like
those topics and how those are the
pillars of education and research during
a time when education and research and
participation are evolving is some of
the most interesting things. And so to
be able to read evolutionary papers
that take a cool scope and approach
and then connect it to how we're
hopefully organizing together and
including the affordance to participate
with anyone who's listening now,
it's an interesting mixture. So I hope
that we all can just keep on learning
and applying together. All right,
peace. Thanks, guys. Thanks again.